I'm technical director of game parts
yeah come is next generation survival
game like 2.0 version we played
everything what is available in this
rivals honor and we wanted to see what
is good and what is wrong with this with
each other and how to improve it so we
came up with the idea that if you like
to make the survival game you need to do
proper simulation of the stuff so our
main the bottom line is we do the most
advanced simulation of human body and
metabolism and this is the baseline for
everything because with other games we
can travel that all players are the same
so if we have the better metabolism is
easy to people you get different bodies
so you are what you eat so if you eat
good the end exercise you can have the
more muscles will be positive
yeah human punch harder Madonna yeah and
we break every foods to basic elements
like proteins carbs Viper so - yeah yeah
yeah the idea and because of that then
you can play a game very easily because
even because it's realistic it's much
easier to play it because you don't need
to eat every second like in other games
you can even go two or three days
without food that's not the problem
but in the end maybe it will reflect on
your stamina or health so you don't have
the problem in long run so you can end
up - game very easily but if you like to
make the sugar soldier you can do it and
that's the best the freedom that we are
over so neither one player will be the
same in the game because of that
based on
yeah yeah yeah even if you start with
two templates for the character and you
go around in world when you meet each
other after maybe two days you'll be
probably different because of that
yeah
yeah Declan corporation is holding
prisons
so there are deals was because their
prisons were populated they wanted to
buy island and remove the citizen from
the island and then make the huge prison
out of it and after some time they
wanted more money so they went that TV
show where they stream what is happening
on the island so we have like drones
that monitor you scan you can track you
and because people can escape from the
prison they gave them this you chip on
your head and this is also great in that
situation because we Teddy you can
monitor your life metabolism starts so
you there's the explanation for the card
they have on your screen and they also
check you with that chip and your head
will explode if you try to escape the
game is hardcore survival sandbox game
and you can try to survive it other
players what is also great is RPGs
system that you can disable points to
put to your strength intelligence maybe
Constitution
yep and after that they'll be a starting
point but what you do in the world needs
to change for example you can build up
your strength over time you can learn
other skills so everything you do you
get experience points for example if I'm
trying to swim I will get better at it
if I'm trying to shoot with the ball
I'll be better at it plastic stuff like
in Skyrim or Oblivion games and because
of that you will not be expert in all
fields there is no way and because of
that we are trying to push people to get
together so you will be food that
medical skill I will be good with
sniping maybe hand-to-hand combat so if
we got together maybe we can rule some
area of the map so
yeah we also can single-player campaign
yeah currently on early access we'll
start with basic stuff it will be a
multiplayer game same as a multiplayer
without other players for the start so
you can try to survive hunt animals poop
and fight with your own body because
there is dangerous animals on the island
so you need also to you can do that and
they they start and later on you'll try
to add some mission how to survive or
escape that prison
yeah we have nice idea I hope you
achieve everything
yes
[Music]
the events
right now
in
yep
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
hydration
[Music]
I need to do
[Music]
I will try to escape into the boots all
right
let's do it here
finish the IOP exclusive this
Mississippi
yeah oh oh oh oh we track everything
everything you got your Bible being
tracked
yeah stomach soluble protein our wiper
motor should get it fixed I can go into
first nice for Simone yeah we will also
give a different combat style like the
quantou we tie over time you can show
you
let's try to well now I'm in combat with
a knife for exchange with you actually I
can also try to talk like
like any man pickup knife again
News for example a case I can pass which
we just
so you can see nearly most of all thing
I can go behind and show you the
penetration is it here yeah it's here
yeah yeah Haven bullet can tumble inside
material and exit to a different
location
yeah I can show you
very interesting it's like almost
well this is registering for but it's so
many realist
try to find something inside baby food
but I will need to have the knife or
something to open this game before speak
yeah we have hundreds of different items
let me show you some stuff pickup zone
because we were made additional my
poster
and stuff that you picked up which is
basically clear like things that you
have to personal yeah but you can also
create some simple stuff these are high
military grade stuff so every backpack
physical space invaded a theory so you
can overload I can open this knife eat
this I can use the kill grenade right
now
or gasoline
at all
unreal baby
you can also I hope did somebody not
kill me
so this is like the spawn
whoa yeah we made just small warm-up
gear to go faster with ya before before
the event
other body
before crazy
no event demanda starting
we are not doing that team based I'll
carve off everyone has the proper table
so let's equip
you can customize skin color and choose
one and predefined faces we will the end
over time as you can see from the energy
field who Excel also policy
yeah ideas do not escape until you are
killed off through the gear okay so
let's go for that key
you can change running speed with the
mouse wheel
let's try to get it first now see the
long flare in the background
yeah there is cargo box and maybe the
keys inside but we are not sure yet and
everything happens here
somebody's maybe living here cooking and
eating maybe hunting but we we have
given at the same time we are doing on
the vehicles not ready yet but it will
be forgiven of course nice now other get
other team found the kids so carbon is
dropping right now
let's go there and they will try to
unlock it
so as you can see there
vaulting
go to the window
walking
all right he went down
a battle for his back yeah
let's go down
you know spoke about fun Joe some
grenades
oh that would be I don't know drop the
kid oh my god let's take it up the
pursuit of the bursa you know you're
safe
what's up David thank you for joining
industry
okay
as you can see sometimes before city
Jews were on this island so we can
police station like Church
that's the church
let's write this we can do that I love
how each building
yeah and also depending on the island
location we can post client with palm
trees and see where you can dive swim
there in temperature is that they're
much higher because this middle part is
1,000 meters high
but this is the cause yeah yeah this is
touristic area water temperature is 25
Celsius air is around so this is
overnight temperature drops so you can
someone even get sick because of that
yeah
yeah currently I don't get any
yeah
nobody oh I think this game
No
yeah let's try it out here ovis initi
okay I can pull a log yes try to secure
the area right now what is also nice oh
yeah
what your players see is what you see so
you cannot like in pop G look around all
over the so there is no different
personal preferences catch someone
complainant have made one because I can
do something like this
up to you let's say around right now you
need to do this
mechanic
nice
to try to set the cargo so right now you
turn around
you can even host event from outside
this is as you can see there is small
barrier around the event but you can be
outside and watch what's happening
inside we also have drones they can
monitor event
due to release probably around two
months so three acids are getting into
fuel to tell them that they they
to console the main problem performances
yeah for the advanced consoles like X 1
X and pH bro it's not the problem but
Sony and the glasses of still want to
support the base in the same you saw
what happened with the pub sheets not
running the trade on the version
in the preview program yeah but so
basically saying it's going to be
putting in hospital
to the base yeah we will try it we'll
see how this is running on the PC we can
easily support American Linux that's not
the problem but for the causes we will
see how this is everything is running
because Unreal Engine is heavy by
default but if you are doing like small
annual tournament style game is possible
but this is the same huge world as we
simulate everything in the real
real-time and this can be a problem
preventable CP or GPU interaction also
takes a song Capone CPU intensive aspect
the LGP yeah we saw how good against
convolution show absolutely present
Thank You size
[Music]